anthony is in kansas city hi anthony
welcome to the dave ramsey show how you
doing
great how can i help um i have about a
half million dollars in my checking
account
and i have had it in there for a couple
years i'm trying to figure out
exactly what to do with it my plan was
to use it for real estate
but the real estate market's got me a
little spooked right now
we live in a college or close to a
college town and
uh the market there they've built so
many brand new complexes in the last
10 years and nobody's going to college
okay i'm with you
exactly the enrollment rates are going
down
um you know so i'm a little bit leery of
that so what town are you in
i'm manhattan kansas yeah okay all right
yep you're far enough away from kansas
city that you're probably not investing
in kansas city right
correct okay anthony how old are you
i'm 45. okay you've done a great job
yeah you have
are you planning to stay in manhattan
that depends um don't necessarily need
to i have a hobby farm
i'm i'm an electrical contractor by
trade
but my my real estate holdings i have a
couple rental properties too but i have
about a million and a half in real
estate
that's all paid for um
about a hundred thousand in cash 500 000
of my checking
[Music]
about 400 000 in other assets like
track loaders and tractors and you're a
stud
well done so proud of you it's got to
feel great man
i mean you really did it and i'm
assuming you did all this start i'm
assuming you did all this starting from
nothing
correct i had nothing inherited nothing
way to go
well here's what i would do if i woke up
in your shoes and i find myself
in similar situations from time to time
i'm between real estate deals
and i need access to the cash when i get
ready to do the next real estate deal
that's where i find myself it's where
you find yourself because you're not
going to drop that half million into
manhattan you've made that decision
i'm not going to recommend if you listen
to me for more than 20 minutes you know
this to be a long distance landlord
and so what i'm going to end up doing is
just parking this
probably in like an s p 500
uh you know a no-load fund there's no
commissions and just ride the market
with it a little bit
while i'm waiting to decide what i'm
going to do
and one of two things will happen one of
three things will happen
you decide to stay in manhattan and the
market gets soft as you predict so you
will not pull that money out and buy in
manhattan
so you're probably going to turn and
invest it in some other
vehicle for probably some mutual funds
or something number two thing that could
happen is you move
and you're living in whatever kansas
city
and you've got a great market to invest
in then you pull the money out
and you invest it then uh what was the
third thing that could happen the third
thing could happen would be manhattan
bounce back
uh the college market firms back up and
you feel good about investing in
manhattan again
pull the money out of the s p and invest
so you're parking it
until something else moves another
variable moves in this situation
but checking account's not okay
yeah and i realize that it's been but
you know how it is time
kind of flies when you're having fun
well and i'm sure your bank is reaching
out
blowing up your phone with all their
ideas and thoughts
are real helpful right now and anthony
mr drysdale's on
paul mr drysdale's on the line there's a
fourth option
you may begin to look at something that
gets to be on sale
where you've got someone that has to
sell or is looking to sell
and now you've put yourself in a
situation to start to have some
conversations
about potentially buying yeah that that
could happen as the market healed
right in manhattan that's right uh that
somebody couldn't quite survive the turn
and it's making an upward turn and
you're comfortable with it that could
result in a really good purpose great
deal yeah that's that's a very very good
point
uh dr john dolone is you know one of his
three
32 degrees he's got he's got more
degrees than a thermometer
is in higher ed and he's talked about
with you and i
and a bunch of us behind the scenes and
even some of what on the air
um that to the extent that
because of the student loan debacle and
because kovitzen everybody home and they
realized
uh these colleges are trying to charge
us just as much sitting at home
um i'm not getting like the college
experience i don't see any iv on the
walls here
right at my house uh so to those two
things hitting together
are accelerating p the demand
for college degrees on campus living
college degrees
they're accelerating that demand
dropping right
it's been dropping we saw the student
loan the covet thing has pushed it over
the edge
and so we are seeing some things like
he's describing a college town like
manhattan
which is what kansas state right yep
it's kansas state
and um so uh you know we're seeing so
many smaller towns where the economy is
driven by college students
that's right it's affecting their
economies it really is there's a lot of
those around america